-Thank you so much, July.
It is just such a treat to
get an introduction from Judy.
I've been waiting
all year for that.
A note of gratitude
and recognition
for the Wampanoag,
Massachusetts, and area tribes
on whose land I'm
operating this talk.
And of course, I'm deeply
grateful to Radcliffe, to Judy,
to Sharon, Rebecca, Mervi--
[? quitos ?] to Mervi
if she's here-- and everyone who
makes this amazing fellowship
possible.
My research partner,
Kaipo, is here, Mira,
and Christina, who've
truly been equals
as we delve into
historical research
and complex ethical
and cultural questions,
and who've been a delight
to spend a year with.
And a huge mahalo to
my fellow Fellows.
Just every week I'm
dazzled, I'm inspired,
and the world just keeps
enlarging and looking
completely new to me.
Now I see the world,
and I see algorithms.
I never saw algorithms before.
Hydrogels.
There's hydrogels in the world.
And that's just
been such a treat,
and it's been a year of
incredible learning and growth,
so thank you so much.
And finally, I want to
thank my dad for flying out.
He's here.
There is a Hawaiian idea
that we carry our ancestors
on our shoulders, and it's
not just me who's here.
It's my entire family and my
people, and that means a lot.
And my dad's physically
present, so that's a delight.
I'm going to start this talk by
giving you a Hawaiian word that
will offer a sense of
structure and added
meaning to the lecture
as well as branding
the perspective of my work.
That word is mo'olelo, and
it's up here on the slide.
And it encompasses a lot of
meanings-- story, history,
tradition, legend, a
yarn, a chronicle, a myth,
public record, private journal,
and a succession of a talk.
So it holds a lot
in just one word.
It's rare I get to
give my writing context
and invite people into the
research and histories that
ground my creative work, so
this opportunity to engage
the multiple
meanings of mo'olelo,
multiple disciplines, multiple
sources, is a real treat.
Mo'olelo has, in its structure,
two other important words
that matter to today's talk.
There's mo', which means
succession, and can
refer to a geological line.
And then olelo, which means
language, speech, an utterance,
an oral presentation.
This is the cover
of my first book,
which was published by
an imprint of Random
House in 2013.
The project I'm working on now
is titled To Weave with Water,
and it's a
multi-generational novel.
It toggles between the early
20th and 21st centuries,
and it's inspired by real
events that occur between 1903
and then 2007 and 2008.
Not only am I
weaving time periods,
but I'm also weaving
character perspectives.
And there are four
central characters
whose interiority the
reader experiences, and I'll
be reading from three of
those characters today.
To ground this
talk, it make sense
to start by looking at Hawaii.
It's an archipelago,
and when you're there,
you're the farthest from
any continental land
mass you can be.
If you have flown
in to Honolulu,
to the capital, or Waikiki,
you've been on Oahu.
If you've seen the
volcano, you've
been on the island of
Hawaii, or big island.
And if you're in the
world of my novel,
you're here on Maui,
especially this eastern side
of the island.
I could tell you a lot about the
origins of the Hawaiian people.
I can lecture on Austronesian
Migration Theory, or seafaring,
or the contemporary
revival of seafaring,
but I'm going to focus
on one origin story,
and that's how Kanaka Maoli,
native Hawaiians-- that's
how they come into being,
and also their relationship
with kalo or taro.
Taro, as probably most
of you know, is a tuber.
It often has little-- it
can be purplish and have
little things coming out of it.
We'll see a picture in a moment.
It's an origin for
the Hawaiian people
and it also serves as an
origin story for my novel.
He Kumulipo is a
genealogical account
of the origins of
the Kanaka Maoli.
One version of it, Wakea, Sky
Father, and Papahanaumoku,
Earth Mother, who,
in this cosmology,
are both siblings
and spouses, are
the parents of the
islands of Hawaii, Maui,
and, later, Kauai.
And with different
partners, they'll
actually birth the
other islands, as well.
They also give birth to a
daughter, Ho'ohokukalani,
to generate stars in the sky.
Wakea desires Ho'ohokukalani,
and, with her,
produces Haloa-naka,
quivering long stock.
But Haloa-naka is an
unformed fetus, a stillbirth,
and they grieve the loss of this
first child and they bury him.
And from this place
where they bury
him sprouts the
first taro plant.
The second child they have is
named Haloa, after his eldest
brother, and he's the
first Hawaiian Ali'i Nui
and becomes the ancestor
of all the Hawaiian people.
One of things that's so
moving to me in this narrative
is that, from a moment of
profound grief and loss--
the loss of a child--
something new, and sustainable,
and really quite beautiful is
created for future generations.
Now, there are multiple cultural
and historical metaphors
that arise from this
story, and I wrote up
there recommended reading--
Lilikala's Native Land
and Foreign Desires,
which delves
into a number of
these metaphors.
But the two I'm going to ask
you to remember for this talk
are, 1, the Kanaka Maoli
have a familial relationship
to the land.
And as family, we're asked
to malama 'aina, care
for the land.
And then 2, that Haloa, the
taro, is our older brother.
And so we're also asked to care
for kalo-- taro-- and the lo'i,
the taro patches
where the taro grows.
Now, you might be
thinking, this sounds
like a really cool
cosmology, but what does
it have to do with right now?
The answer's a lot, still.
The narrative about
Haloa-naka and Haloa
shapes our decisions, our
ethics and morals, our culture
and tradition.
And you see I've actually
used contemporary photos here
to illustrate just how
alive the taro and taro
farming is on the islands.
Here are lo'i in Ke'anae
on the east side of Maui.
And here are taro.
They're ready to clean and cook.
And then here, Uncle Vince
Dodge is poi pounding.
He's pounding the
taro on a ku'i ai,
a poi board that's made of
wood, with a po'haku ku'i ai,
a stone for pounding.
And when you add water
to the pounded taro,
that's when you get poi.
And that's the staple
of the Hawaiian diet.
OK, so we're going to hold
this present tense history,
as I like to call
it, in one hand here,
and we're going to travel back
in time to the 19th century.
In 1819, the American
Board of Commissioners
for Foreign Missions,
the ABCFM, sends,
out of Boston, its
first missionaries
to the Hawaiian Islands, and
they arrive in March of 1820.
So there's a really strong
tie between Boston and Hawaii.
One of the strong
ties is actually
that Hawaii's water law is
based on Boston's water law.
Fun facts also might matter
later-- just letting you know.
Lahainaluna Seminary
is founded--
a number of seminaries
are founded,
but Lahainaluna is the first.
It considers itself the oldest
school west of the Rockies,
founded in 1831.
It's also my dad's alma mater.
And it houses the
first printing press
where the first Hawaiian
language newspaper is printed.
By mid-century, Hawaii is one
of the most literate nations
in the world.
Some scholars think it was
the most literate nation
in the world.
Now, the children
and grandchildren
of the first missionaries
established sugar cane
plantations, and
these are names that
might be familiar because they
have family ties on the East
Coast, as well.
Alexander and Baldwin, Gay and
Robinson, Castle and Cooke,
and of course Dole.
And a lot of these
early plantations
now are huge corporations.
The missionary families forced
the Hawaiian monarchy's hand.
They pressed for the
privatization of land,
and then they come to control
a large portion of it.
Hawaiians are the first
plantation workers,
but as their population
is decimated by disease,
the plantation owners
begin to import workers.
So in 1852, the Chinese arrived,
followed soon after by Japanese
and Portuguese.
And then, in the
early 20th century,
Okinawans, Koreans, Puerto
Ricans, and Filipinos
will follow.
A strict plantation
hierarchy is maintained.
So for example,
Portuguese workers,
who are European in origin,
but have slightly darker
skin than the
American Missionary
descendants-- they're
allowed to be foremen.
So they're above
the Asian settlers,
but they're below the
descendant owners.
Pay scale, where
people live, what jobs
they're allowed to have--
all this is based on race.
In 1893, these wealthy American
plantation owners stage a coup,
and they overthrow
the Hawaiian monarchy.
They imprisoned Queen
Liliuokalani in Iolani Palace.
Grover Cleveland, US President
at the time, condemns the coup,
but soon William McKinley
steps into office.
He negotiates a treaty with
the new Republic of Hawaii,
which is under Sanford B.
Dole, to use the Naval base
at Pearl Harbor, as the Spanish
American War is looming.
Annexation is fought
very strongly.
98% of the Hawaiian
population, along with a number
of Asian settlers, sign
anti-annexation petitions.
And this is an example
of one on the screen.
And I found my family's
names on these, as well.
But in 1898, US Congress
annexes the Hawaiian Islands.
And it's in this moment
that my novel begins.
It begins in 1903.
A young Hawaiian
woman named [? Mele ?]
has been schooled at the
Mauna'olu Female Seminary
on Maui.
It's a real place, though
she is a fictional character.
She's inspired by young women
like these pictured here.
These photos are from a
female seminary in Honolulu.
And much like these
young women, she
is caught between worlds--
the Hawaiian culture
and knowledge and language
of her early years,
and the missionary education
of her preteen and adolescence.
As the novel opens, she's 16,
one of the eldest at Mauna'olu,
where she was sent
10 years prior,
the year of the
overthrow, to be educated
in English, mathematics,
American history,
and the domestic arts.
But she's already 16, so
she's aging out of the school.
And so she's faced
with a choice to either
return to her father and
the rural east side of Maui,
or take a position
as a domestic servant
for an American
plantation family.
"Even if they were
born into poverty,
Mele thinks, Mauna'olu
makes them rich.
The taste for
oranges they develop.
The delight in fine lace,
which they learn to make.
The hand-me-down scraps
of summer wool and velvet
they used to fashion a collar,
are sew cuffs on a blouse.
After years at school,
how can they ever
return to the ways
of their parents?
They no more wish to dip
their fingers in the poi bowl
than they desire to live
in a grass-thatched hale.
When Mele last visited
her family years ago,
she found their living
quarters unseemingly,
their closeness claustrophobic.
Bodies and skin, sticky with
salt. The breath, hot and damp,
pressed against her
until, at last, she
found respite in a corner far
from her father and grandmother
and siblings.
Mele remembers her first
night at Mauna'olu.
How she peered
beneath her mattress
to see the ropes
on which it rested,
because she had never before
slept elevated from the ground.
And how she poked at the pillow
to watch it exhale a feather.
She felt herself singular then,
special, chosen, the child
given to missionary schooling.
That first morning, awaking
in her elevated bed,
she had been dressed by one
of the graduates, a girl named
Luka, who was the same
age then as Mele is now,
and who gave her a blue
calico sash for her dress.
Later, when the water
pumps failed, as they often
did and still do, Luka
was asked to search
for the buckets lost in the
cistern beneath the school.
Mele held her breath
while the brave older girl
descended into darkness.
A splash, then silence.
One of the teachers pressed
Mele's face to her skirt
as if she understood
Mele's fear.
When Luka finally reemerged,
she had the expression
of a newborn.
Face squeeze tight
against the light,
hands curled into fists, a
bucket hung from each forearm,
and one from her left ankle.
She had found three, not
just the missing two.
Her dress clung to her sturdy
body, the nascent curves
of womanhood beginning to show.
How she was laughing.
That's what Mele remembers most.
Luka's open mouth.
Her white teeth,
straight and strong.
The promise that here,
at Mauna'olu, everything
could always be made right.
The girls followed Luka.
Crowded into the doorway of
the kitchen, their curling
laughter rising
upward, their fingers
tugging at the
dress encasing her.
Wet fabric peeled
from brown skin.
Luka ran up the stairs in
just an underskirt and slip,
and Headmistress gathered the
sopping clothing abandoned
on the kitchen floor, proclaimed
she would wash and dry it
herself.
'Such a brave girl,'
she told the others.
'Such a good example
for all of you.'
Now, years later,
Mele is the one
who owns these
duties, who manages
the steaming basins
in the wash house,
and goes searching for lost
buckets in the cistern.
Mele, who's been chosen
to uphold tradition.
If she leaves, who will
climb down the wooden ladder
into the gaping
mouth of the earth?
Who will pose above the water,
dress hems soaking in the cold?
Who will know how
deep a breath to take?
How to dive into darkness,
to swim with feet kicking,
descending farther and farther?
In the cistern,
everything is black.
No up or down, no right or left.
A girl who doesn't know better
might panic, drown even.
Only Mele knows that when
you cannot figure which way
to turn, hold still.
Let the air in your
lungs carry you upward.
If only every decision were this
easy, she thinks, this natural.
Hold still and your body
will tell you what to do.
At the same time
that Mele is debating
whether to return
home or not, East Maui
is experiencing an influx
of Japanese workers
who've been hired to
construct the Ko'olau Ditch.
Built between 1903 and
1904, the Ko'olau Ditch
extends the East Maui
Irrigation System
deep into the rainy,
windward side of the island."
And to give you a sense--
all these ditches were built
in the late 1800s,
and what they're doing
is they're drawing water
from the windward side that
gets a lot of rain into the
dry Central Valley, where
sugar cane is grown.
And they need the water not
only the water the cane fields,
but also to mill it.
And this line here
is the Ko'olau Ditch.
Its construction was overseen by
Michael Maurice O'Shaughnessy,
and he's the engineer who will,
upon his return from Hawaii,
design the Hetch-Hetchy
project that brings water
to the city of San Francisco.
So this is really where
he makes his name.
The Ko'olau Ditch is one of
the great feats of engineering,
and there's tons of papers
about it from this time
and in, actually,
like the next 50
years that follow-- this
project and another project he
did on Kauai.
You have a sense, I think,
of the danger and the majesty
of this side of the island when
you look at this waterfall.
The waterfalls are huge.
Haleakala, the
mountain, is very steep.
And on the east side of
Maui, the valleys and peaks
fold so tightly it's like
looking at an accordion.
What you probably can't see is
that, up here on this bridge,
which is going to connect
two tunnel mouths,
are the tunnel men who
are building these tunnels
and ditches and siphons--
this whole water
system-- to draw this water
to the Central Valley.
The tunnel men are almost
exclusively Japanese.
There are a few Hawaiian crews,
and there's Portuguese luna.
According to O'Shaughnessy,
the Japanese men
are stronger than
the Chinese, more
reliable than the
Hawaiians, and cheaper
to pay than everybody else.
And it's because of the lowest
in the plantation hierarchy.
Tunnel mouths are exploded using
[? vigorate ?] powder, which
they ship from San Francisco.
They pack that into boreholes
with a fuse, and they light it.
And they hope they
get away in time.
The [? vigorate ?]
is highly explosive.
Once they've opened up the
mouth, they then hand drill.
And I mentioned up, I
think-- these tunnels
can be 2,000-- the longest
one is 2,700 feet long.
The shortest is 300.
They average 1,000 feet.
So they're really long.
And that's really hard earth.
[? Joji, ?] another fictional
character, is one such tunnel
man.
He's in charge of the
[? vigorate ?] powder, used
to explode the entrances.
Just before the excerpt
I'm about to read,
Joji's two closest friends
have died in an accident.
A retaining wall has
collapsed and the tunnel
they were working on flooded.
"Joji and his protege,
Shota, survived the flood,
but they witnessed
their friends drowning."
One other character appears
here-- the okolehao man.
Okolehao is the
Hawaiian word for swipe,
so liquor made from, in this
case, ti root-- the ti plant.
And the men call him Hao,
which is Chinese for good.
So Hao is a Hawaiian
man who brews swipe,
and he sells it in these
Japanese workers' camps.
"The first time Joji buys drink,
Shota asks to come with him.
They share a bottle.
At the far edge of camp,
away from the luna's tents,
they sit on bales of hay
meant for the donkeys who
are tied up nearby.
Some of the men draw a circle
in the dirt and throw dice.
Others retire to a
quiet game of cards.
But Joji and Shota stay with
Hao to listen to him talk.
He's a good storyteller-- not
just funny tales, but others.
An avid fisherman,
once he caught a shark
and thought he was Maui
himself pulling up new land.
The island fought, its
body reflecting the sun
in one moment, and
in the next, becoming
a shadow beneath the water.
But when Hao glimpsed a dorsal
fin, he realized what he had.
'I cut the line,' he admits.
'Sometimes you
have no fight left,
but sometimes you
just respect the fight
of another more than your own."
Later, near the early
morning, Shota speaks.
'Our friends are dead,' he
says, then goes silent again.
His eyes are unfocused.
His lips hang open,
their wet saliva
gathering in the soft center.
Hao does not make a joke,
does not reply with a story.
'Tell me,' he says.
And he listens as Shota
describes the cave, the water,
the hours of waiting.
Joji notices that Shota does
not mention the body that
floated beneath them.
They have not spoken of it with
anyone, not even each other.
Shota is crying, and
Joji, embarrassed,
does not know what to do.
But Hao understands.
He tucks his hand beneath
Shota's good arm, lifts him up.
'Let's walk you to
the bunk house.'
Joji returns with
increasing frequency,
but Shota refuses
to go back to Hao.
'That drink hurts going down
and coming back up,' Shota says.
He adds, 'remember, Susuma and
Habiki did not like this man,
or his drink.'
Joji does not listen.
After all, the drink is
what allows him to sleep.
At the end of a
shift, the okolehao
loosens the shoulders,
the legs, the mind.
Joji feels warm, easy, as if
swimming in a summertime pond.
Later, his mouth
is that of a fish.
Map, map, map.
He cannot control it as
it opens, closes, opens.
Swipe in the morning comes next
to keep the headache at bay,
to moisten his wooden tongue,
to steady his shaking hands.
He can never be second-day
drunk if he is always
on the first day of drinking.
And anyway, he
needs to stay sharp
if he is to help
with the next tunnel.
The boreholes must be
drilled into the rock,
the [? vigorate ?] powder
measured and packed
with accuracy, the fuse
given enough length.
And then he must
have dependable hands
to light the cord,
nimble feet to walk away.
Here, there are few
curves in the mountainside
to hide behind, so
the diggers build
a trench fronted by a berm.
Once, Joji trips over it,
lands in someone's arms
as the [? vigorate ?]
powder blows.
That night, he
crafts his retelling
as if his story were frivolity.
'The booming that
followed, I never know
if it's the explosion
or my headache.'
Hao laughs at that.
The other men, too.
Joji asks Hao what
it feels like to him
when the tunnels
are blasted open.
'Down in the native
village, what do they say
of what's being done
to their mountainside?'
'The boom comes as a feeling
in the feet,' Hao says.
'A trembling at the knees.
It comes as a
weakness in the earth,
then up the length of the body.'
'How you know that not the
hangover?' someone calls out,
and Hao laughs.
'I never know.'
The nights are
all like this one.
The campfire burning
low, so the men's faces
are lost, only their
knuckles showing,
highlighted as they grip their
glass bottles or metal cups.
He thinks, each man is lost
in a cave of his own digging.
Shota's shoulder is healing.
He is already back at
work on the road crew,
using his good arm
to help lay rock.
Joji finds ways to
avoid him now that they
are in different crews,
but he misses the boy,
even as he is ashamed
when Shota spies him.
One morning, Shota catches him
on the road between shifts.
'Sansei," Shota calls
out, the old nickname
rising like a reproach.
'You look sick.' The boy's
country Chugokuan accent
reminds Joji of how he is
surrounded by bumpkins.
What does Shota know
of illness or grief?
'Feeling fine," Joji presses
on, but Shota chases after him.
'Sansei, you cannot keep
on with the okolehao.'
'I'm not keeping on.'
'But you are.' The boy is at his
elbow, clinging like seaweed.
He shakes him off.
'I just want my friend
back,' the boy murmurs.
Joji turns.
Shota's left arm is
still on a sling,
but the other has
grown muscular.
His neck has new veins,
a taut line of strength.
The boy has been
keeping his hair short.
Who has been cutting it
for him, if not Joji?
And he looks older,
handsome even.
His expression is
one of deep sadness.
'No more,' he says.
Shota is not begging.
Not even asking.
He is willing it to be so.
'No more.
None.'
Joji stumbles away from
him toward the tunnel,
toward another day of
digging through darkness.
The whirring noise
of the handrails
drowns the ringing in the ears.
More, he thinks.
More swipe.
More stories.
More laughter.
More Hao.
More okolehao.
The next night, Joji
invites Hao to share
his dinner-- some rice and ume.
And the night after that,
Hao bring sweet potato paste,
made rich with coconut milk.
They eat together, a
flat rock their table.
Above them, the stars
are crystalline.
A rare night like this
has beauty, brightness.
Joji remembers one such in
Yokohama, how the moon glinted
off the ocean, and
his father pointed
to the outline of a Dutch
trading ship in the distance.
Joji has never told
anyone about this moment.
The thrill of it.
The possibility of that
single clipper, its sails
set ablaze by the aquatic moon.
Hao listens.
He speaks of his own life, too.
His one living child
in seminary school.
He has lost a baby girl, the
youngest, to bubonic plague,
and two sons to scarlet fever.
His wife was sent
to the leper colony.
Illness is a specter
in his life--
a malevolent spirit he and
his people cannot shake.
Yet he finds delight
in the water,
in the streams that run from
the mountains to the ocean.
'I grow my kalo with that water,
my sweet potatoes,' Hao says.
'I bathe my mother
with that water.'
'Bathe her?' Joji repeats,
and then immediately is sorry.
Hao's features squeeze
the center of his face.
'She is ill, but the
water makes her happy.
On a good day, she can sit in
the stream, splash herself.
On the bad days, I
wipe her in our hale.
I feed her.
She is like an infant.
She suckles my finger
when I dip it in poi.'
Joji cannot imagine caring
for a grown human in this way.
'I feel alone,' Hao admits,
his words heavy. 'I am alone.
My daughter refuses to return.
She thinks I want money.
I have a business.
Why would I want money?
I want her here with me.
I want her with her family.'
Joji nods as if he understands.
He feels sorry for
Hao, and that makes
him feel sorry for himself.
He is without family,
without company.
Sosume and Habiki are dead.
The self-pity sweetens
his drink somehow.
Shoto arrives hance the
edge of the campfire.
'Tell them,' Joji calls to him.
'Tell them how we saw
Sosume and Habiki.
Tell them how we saw
the body at the end.'
Shota shakes his head, refuses.
Joji feels angry.
Why will the boy not tell Hao?
Why will he not
tell all of them?
Joji wants everyone to
know what he's endured.
Shota is speaking,
but he's not saying
what Joji wants him to say.
Joji stands, stumbles
toward the boy.
Hao is on his feet, too.
Shota is telling
him, 'be quiet, now.'
'Get away from me,
you,' Joji yells.
He kicks dirt at the fire, but
his words are meant for Shota.
'Get away.
You're insincere.
You're a boy who
doesn't understand.
You have no virtues.'
He awakes much later.
His body is hot and
shivering at once.
His sweat has an animal scent.
He wants to bathe, to leap into
a deep, cold pool of water,
but he's still drunk.
And he knows if he
stands, he'll fall over.
He remembers Shota
saying to keep quiet.
Not to speak.
And he understands now why
the boy kept hushing him.
Gaman, the quiet endurance
that has marked him
as someone worthy of respect.
After last night, no longer so.
The hair at his neck
clings damply to his skin.
A few hours later
he awakes again,
this time with a sick
sensation in his stomach.
He is sick from the words
of the night before.
He insulted Shota when
the boy was only trying
to help him keep his dignity.
Joji drags himself
upright, exits the tent.
At the end of his
row is a washbasin
where he splashes his face.
He decides, as pennance, to
go without drink for the day.
He will make it up
to Shota in that way.
He will suffer through the
shaking hands and pounding head
and rasping cough,
unsoothed by the swipe,
and all this will
make him virtuous,
worthy of forgiveness.
He will go to the boarding
house in the evening
and find Shota and
apologize, and the boy
will see he has been clean
all day, and forgive him.
On the walk to the
tunnel, he keeps his hands
in his pocket to
quell the shaking.
Today, they need the backside
of tunnel 11 blasted,
so he prepares the powder.
He is slow and careful as ever,
but his hands are unsteady.
Twice he drops a portion
of the [? vigorate ?]
has to gather the red earth
on which it fell, toss it
over the side of the cliff.
Diluted, it will not
accidentally explode.
He's sweating again.
His shirt damp, his
armpits squeaky.
He lights the fuse at last
and turns to walk away,
his tread careful.
He stumbles, feet
mismanaged by the brain,
and plunges forward,
catches himself.
He has to pause to sort
his legs, his torso.
The luna, voice soft and
cautious because of the powder,
hisses, 'come, Jo, come.' The
urgency and fear in his voice
is palpable.
Joji pushes himself to the
berm, one foot after the next.
He wonders if his
shoes are untied,
if he has time to retie them.
He pauses.
The luna's face is pale.
The man ducks
behind the hillock.
Joji clamors over
into the trench.
And then the boom, the
raining of rocks-- how they
make that scattering noise.
He looks up at plant roots
overturned, bristling
from the bank of earth.
He stands again,
legs steadier now.
Mind, too.
He climbs back over the berm.
He moves quickly, wants
to be the first there.
Not his usual calm,
his usual patience.
He knows the sound was different
this time-- shallower, shorter.
He wonders if they've
hit another lava tube.
He will apologize to Shota
after this shift ends.
He went too far last
night, spoke to freely.
The okolehao brings
that out of him.
He'll take a night or
two off from the swipe,
return to it with
greater control.
He steps forward to study the
rock, its angle of sheering.
Far to his right
is a trail of cord.
His mind is slow to
respond to what it means--
the borehole unexploded.
He reaches his hand forward as
if he could re-pack the powder.
His fingers graze the rock,
and then the world convulses."
And now we jump 100
years in the future.
By the late 20th century,
Alexander N. Baldwin, or ANB,
the last sugar cane
plantation on Maui,
and soon to be the last
in all the islands,
through their subsidiary,
East Maui Irrigation, EMI,
has diverted over 100 East Maui
streams collected on 33,000
acres of conservation lands.
And they use this water to
irrigate their sugar cane
fields, which is managed by
another ANB subsidiary, HCNS,
Hawaiian Commercial and Sugar.
In the mid-1990s, a group
of East Maui taro farmers,
gatherers, and fishers, form a
group called Na Moku Aupuni O
Ko'olau Hui.
It's a community
organization that,
with the native
Hawaiian legal core,
sues ANB and EMI for their
constitutional rights
to access water and
pursue Hawaiian traditions
and customs dependent
on free-flowing streams.
The Ko'olau Ditch is the
center of that lawsuit.
Here's a view of the
East Maui town, Ke'anae.
I took this photo, and
I'm standing on the road.
And not far behind me is one
of the Ko'olau Ditch intakes.
You can see here
the lo'i, the taro
patches-- one being farmed here.
You can also see where they've
had to let their lo'i go,
and just be grown
over with grass
because they don't have
the water to plant them.
This very real
lawsuit is actually
what first drew me to the
subject matter of my novel.
Later, I did this
historical research.
So the bulk of this talk
came much later, actually.
But first and foremost
were these taro farmers.
Now, all my writing
circles around questions.
I don't write because
I know something.
I write because
I'm really trying
to understand it, and
especially understand
it personally and emotionally
as well intellectually.
So this lawsuit, which is about
water rights and native rights,
has, for me, a very
deep, human component.
Several of the lead plaintiffs
grew up with my dad and uncle
and were classmates
with my dad and uncle.
When the lawsuit starts,
they're in their 50s.
They're not young guys.
They're starting to
complain about the arthritis
in their knees and they're
feeling a little creaky.
Maybe they're losing some hair.
And they don't fit the image
of people who are radical,
but what they do is radical.
At this point, in the
late 90s, early 2000s,
ANB is the single
largest employer on Maui.
They own Matson
Shipping Lines, which
is how Hawaii gets its food,
its clothing, its building
materials, it's everything.
They have connections in
every level of the government,
and a close connection
to the governor herself.
So when these Hawaiians
stand up to all that,
their litigation
challenges and reorients
not only the present moment,
but an entire history
of plantation colonialism.
There are definitely other
Hawaiians and community groups
doing amazing work in the same
period, and earlier, and since,
but this group is moving to me
because their narrative is also
tied to the Haloa narrative.
Remember, they're taro farmers.
So they're taking from a
moment of grief and loss--
for more than a century
of grief and loss--
and creating something
new and sustainable
for future generations.
So in this final
excerpt, I'm going
to focus on the fictional
character Henry.
he's retired when
this excerpt begins.
He grows kalo in a town on
the eastern side of Maui
that might look much like this.
And he's involved in
a lawsuit inspired
by the one I just described.
To orient you,
Ellen is his wife.
His daughter is Kolea.
And he had a son, too,
whose name was Pue'o,
and who disappeared 10
years prior to this excerpt.
His body's never
been found, but it's
thought he died cliff or
bridge jumping somewhere
along the Irrigation System.
"The baby tries, Henry thinks.
He sees her bare arms, the
tight muscles of them, the way
her shoulder muscles
gleam in the sun.
She's working hard in the lo'i.
When she bends over, her back
stooped, her eyes squinting,
she reminds him
of his grandmother
who, at the end of her life,
watched him like a coiled eel
in her bed.
Funny how he connects
the old woman
to his daughter who is still
young and open to the world.
'Time for eat,' he
calls out to Kolea.
She waves to let him know she
heard, but she doesn't stop.
She has a way of holding off
simple pleasures in the name
of completing a task.
She is fierce in this respect,
a harder worker than anyone
he knows, himself included.
From the dried grass ground,
she lifts each oha and murmurs
to it.
He has never asked her
what she says to the corm,
has never wanted her
to feel embarrassed,
to stop speaking to the
taro the way she does.
He is convinced the
kalo hears her, listens,
wants to survive to
hear her voice again.
Henry slips his knife
beneath the skin of a mango
and cuts a spiral around the
fruit until the exterior comes
off in a single coil.
Then he cuts himself
a slice, chews
it, the flesh
sweet and unctuous,
the juice on his hands.
Watching Kolea, he feels
the old worry rise,
a tide slow and predictable.
He still can't, after
all these years,
stop himself from worrying.
Ellen doesn't
worry like he does.
Ellen understands, now
that Kolea is a woman,
how to relate to her as such.
The two of them--
those two women
circling each
other in his house.
But here, in the lo'i, Kolea
is both woman and child,
and when the sun shimmers
in the noonday sky,
he thinks he sees his little
girl splashing in the water,
planting her first kalo.
Taking his hand when
the police told them
they have to stop the
search for Pue'o's body,
Henry remembers
those days acutely,
even when he struggles to recall
most recently passed hours.
He worries that Kolea will
step on an old mango pit
and cut her foot.
And he worries she will
slice her hand with a knife.
He worries when she
drives to see friends
after a beer with him
that she'll go too fast
and miss one of the curves.
He worries she'll meet the wrong
kind of man, one who is cruel,
or an addict, or a Playboy.
Or that she'll meet the right
kind of man and then what will
he say?
He worries she will say she
made other plans for dinner,
and he worries that
she'll stay but declined
to watch the Raiders game.
Together, these big and
small fears weigh on him,
and he tamps down the worries
by calling out to her again,
'Hey, time for [? pao." ?]
He waits for her to respond.
Is he always waiting
to hear her voice?
Is that what makes him a
father, that he is always
waiting for his children
to come back to him?
Her reply is lost in
the heat of the earth.
Lost to the mountain above them.
Lost in the water between them.
And this is his greatest
fear, that he will lose her.
Then she's outside of the lo'i,
rinsing her arms and legs,
her hands rubbing against each
other to wipe away the earth.
She's beside him, reaching
for a mango slice."
And finally, in this very brief
section that ends this chapter,
Henry spends some time
recalling the maps he studied
after his son's disappearance.
And he became so
adept at reading them
that his friends,
who are at this point
about to launch the lawsuit,
ask that he kind of become
the expert on watersheds
and the EMI system.
And so he kind of begins to see
himself as this expert of maps.
So this closing
meditation from Henry
is where I'll end my mo'olelo.
And I hope it also
brings new meaning
to the first story I told you.
"The maps.
That was how it all started.
In the years that followed,
as he and his friends
gathered their research, when
they were finally assigned
a lawyer, and filed the
lawsuit against the plantation;
as they fought for
return of the water
that had been taken from
them 100 years prior;
as their kids left
adolescence for adulthood,
and then left their homes
to make homes of their own;
as their belly grew and their
hairlines shrunk, and those
muscled shoulders became
smaller, or even-hunched;
as they cut down to part
time or, in Henry's case,
retired completely; as they
passed their businesses
onto their children,
or, for Jean,
as they struggled to make their
children understand that what
they did they did for them,
they became the
faces of the lawsuit.
Some newspapers lampooned them.
Others celebrated their cause.
They attended
community meetings.
They watched the
water commissioner
be replaced four times.
They were accused of
being water terrorists.
They were lauded as
cultural saviors.
That night, in bed
beside Ellen, Henry
dreamed in mapped landscapes,
his imagination unfurling
on a grid, organized by
neatly delineated quadrants.
And when he awoke, age lending
a dull resistance to sleep,
then the contours of his wife's
body resembled watersheds.
Even in their lovemaking,
he'd sometimes
look down at her breasts, still
firm after all these years,
but heavier than they
had been in her youth,
and determine how
a drop of sweat
might belong to one
valley or another,
depending on the
angle of decline.
He lost himself in
those maps, just
as his son had been
lost to him somewhere
in the folds of this island.
And Ellen, too, was soon seduced
by the ascents and descents,
the swerving lines,
the possibility
that one of these times,
when they unfurled the map,
they would understand
where their son had gone."
Thank you.